we previously discussed the concept of
conservation of momentum we will soon
see that there is another very powerful
conservation principle in physics called
the conservation of energy it states
that there was a certain quantity called
energy that remains unchanged in the
system except for any that flows in or
out of the system it's hard to say
exactly what energy is it's an abstract
quantity that we count up in a certain
way when calculating the energy of the
system
we must keep careful track of any energy
that enters or leaves the system there
are also a number of different forms of
energy kinetic energy gravitational
energy elastic energy electrical energy
heat energy and others each of these has
its own formula for calculation if you
sum all these energies up for a system
the total will remain unchanged except
for what goes in and comes out it turns
out that using energy rather than force
one can construct a complete system of
mechanics that is fully equivalent to
the Newtonian system this was done by
Lagrangian Hamilton and you may
encounter their system in the future if
you take more advanced courses in
physics however even in the Newtonian
system energy remains a useful concept
this week we will discuss kinetic energy
the energy associated with the motion of
a mass and also the concept of work
which allows us to calculate how the
action of a force changes the kinetic
energy we will see that the work done by
a force is calculated by evaluating an
integral that in general depends upon
the specific trajectory or path taken by
the object or system however we will
also see that there was a special class
of forces called conservative forces for
which the work integral is path
independent and instead depends only on
the starting and ending points finally
when we'll discuss examples of both
conservative and non-conservative forces